VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Hello.
Welcome to our talk,
addressing advanced use cases
with new Cloud
Functions capabilities.
I'm Vinod.
I'm a product manager at Google.
SARA FORD: Hi, I'm Sara,
and I'm a Cloud Developer
Advocate at Google.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Just
the overview of our talk.
First, we'll provide
you a product overview
on Cloud Functions.
Then, walk you through
key FaaS and function
as a service use cases.
Then, walk you through the
FaaS programming model.
Then, we'll cover key
performance, scalability
and availability features
in Cloud Functions.
Then, walk you through
key new security features
in Cloud Functions, as well
as cover the cloud event
support that is being added
to Cloud Functions as well.
And to conclude, we'll cover
a couple of exciting demos
provided to you by Sara.
So let's get started.
Cloud Functions.
Cloud Functions is Google
Cloud's event-driven serverless
compute platform.
Cloud Functions lets you
write small snippets of code
that react to events
such as HTTP as well
as asynchronous events.
For example, uploading a file
to a cloud storage bucket
and doing some
processing after that
or sending a message
to [INAUDIBLE]
and processing the
message accordingly.
Cloud Functions are
truly serverless.
They scale seamlessly.
You don't have to manage
any of the infrastructure,
and you pay for what you use.
Further, functions of a
streamlined development model
where you can get
started very quickly
and have it running as well.
In addition, functions are
integrated with different GCP
products through
events as well as HTTP.
Key FaaS use cases that
customers and users
use Cloud Functions are
serverless webhooks.
For example, doing
a GitHub push commit
and then processing a function
and posting a message to Slack.
Real-time data processing
where you can upload files
to a Cloud Storage bucket and
process the data using MLA APIs
and store the result back.
IoT backends, where
temperature and humidity
sensors from all over the world
upload temperature and humidity
data.
This process is by
Cloud Functions,
and you take corrective
action accordingly.
Intelligent applications
such as Twilio chat
bots that upload messages
to Cloud Functions,
which are processed by a
natural language API or BigQuery
for trend analysis.
Functions in the FaaS
programming model
are very easily deployable.
You can deploy a function
from the UI, from the CLI,
through the IDE using functions
frameworks, as well as the API.
Here's a simple example if
you have a snippet of code,
where it's going to
be deployed using
a single command ready to
serve traffic in minutes.
You can deploy these functions
in your favorite programming
language.
We are super excited to
ship these languages to you.
Think about Node, Python,
Go, Java, .NET, Ruby and PHP.
Along with the
programming model,
functions offer key performance,
scalability and availability
capabilities.
We are super excited to
ship the min instances
capability in Cloud Functions.
Cold starts is a real
problem in serverless
where whenever your
function starts up
or your serverless
service starts up,
you have a startup text.
Min instances lets you
mitigate this problem,
which are pre-run instances.
So for example, in this podcast
transcription application,
you can have a set of
pre-run instances with each
of your functions in order
to improve end-to-end latency
of your serverless workflow.
Here is a GitHub
tutorial as well.
Please feel free
to check it out.
Longer processing.
We're super excited to
ship longer processing
with Cloud Functions.
Now you can process your
functions up to 60 minutes.
This capability is in preview.
This is 6x the execution time.
Think about longer data
processing pipelines
and longer ML pipelines.
Along with longer
processing, we're
also shipping larger instances
with Cloud Functions.
Now you can have up to 16 GB
of memory, which is in preview,
as well as the ability
to have multiple CPUs.
So think about larger
in memory operations
as well as like [INAUDIBLE]
parallel applications
with your functions.
They've also expanded the number
of regions that are available
with Cloud Functions, going
to about 22 regions globally.
Along with the other
capabilities we talked about,
we're adding some new
security capabilities
in Cloud Functions.
We are super excited
to ship the integration
with Secrets Manager for
your Cloud Functions.
Now you can securely set
your environment variables
and access them using Secret
Manager in your Cloud Functions
in a programmatic fashion and
making the developer experience
seamless as well.
Along with secrets,
we are also shipping
a capability called
Customer-Managed Encryption
Keys.
So users can provide
user-provided encryption keys,
which can then be used by
GCP to do all the encryption
throughout the function flow.
This gives more
control to the users
and create a level of
encryption as well.
And if the key does not work,
Google cannot even access
the data, and it's completely
in the control of the user.
Shared VPC support.
We're also super excited
to ship this new networking
capability, which
lets your functions
access resources
in a shared VPC.
You can access Compute
Engine resources
as well as on prem systems.
Further, this is within a
secure VPC-SC perimeter,
which is a logical
boundary that adds
additional restrictions such
as only authorized users
can deploy a Cloud Function
within the perimeter
as well as only authorized users
within the perimeter can invoke
a function.
Further, the function can be
configured behind a Cloud Load
Balancer for load
balancing as well.
In addition to the
networking capabilities,
we're also shipping a capability
called private pools that
gives users more
control on their
build time environment
for their Cloud Function.
Users can have more control
and how their Cloud Function
is built, thereby letting users
control the entire software
supply chain of code, build,
and invocations per run.
Along with the
security capabilities,
we are adding cloud event
support through Cloud Functions
as well.
Cloud events are
industry standard events,
which are open and portable,
making your architecture
for the long term as well.
We added cloud event
support for Cloud Functions
by supporting cloud audit logs.
This lets you invoke functions
from over 90 plus GCP products.
For example, every time you
create a compute engine or a VM
instance, you can
now invoke a function
to do some processing
after the VM creation,
such as labeling the VM.
Every time a BigQuery
job finishes,
you can do some processing
after the job is completed.
The same applies for SQL,
Spanner, so on and so forth.
Now, I would like to
hand over to Sara,
who has a couple of interesting
and exciting demos for you
on these capabilities.
SARA FORD: Thanks, Vinod.
In the first demo,
you'll see how
you can use min
instances to keep
a certain number of
your applications
warm to improve performance
time and minimize cold starts.
And the reason why you
might want to do this
is if, for example,
you know you're
going to be receiving
additional traffic soon.
Perhaps it's due to like a Black
Friday, Cyber Monday event,
or you know that
you just need to get
the best possible latency time.
So by keeping a number
of instances warm,
you can help reduce cold
starts and get the best latency
and the response time possible.
So you'll see how that
works in this upcoming demo.
In this first demo, I
have a Node.js function,
and it's already deployed with
min instances set to zero,
which is the default.
So let's take
a look at this function code.
Now, the entry
point is helloWorld.
So that means that all the
code outside of the entry point
is going to be in global scope.
So in other words, here is the
event handler, the entry point
for the function.
So any code outside
of that function,
like here, as you see,
is in global scope.
So line three, where we
call the start up method,
this is going to get executed
any time there is a cold start,
like the instances warming up.
So we'll log that
this is a cold start,
and then you'll see me
simulate a long connection.
This could be something to--
a call to establishing a
connection with the database.
This could be an API call
that takes a while to respond,
but something that you want
to do once, cache that value
and have it available for future
invocations of your function.
And so once this time-out
to sleep comes back,
then you'll see me
log, I'm ready now,
and then return, ready, back.
So here is a code that
is invoked every time--
that is executed every time
the function is evoked.
And I'm using the utility for
just pure debugging purposes
just to illustrate
what is happening.
And it's getting the current
status of the promise.
And if it's still
a cold start, it
reports that, it waits until
the 30 second time-out has
completed, and then
it says, now I'm
warmed up, using the warm emoji.
Otherwise, if it's
already a warm instance,
then it just reports back
that it's a warm instance.
And, of course, it
needs to respond back
to the request with
request completed.
So let's invoke our function
and see this in action.
So on the trigger,
we'll simply click here.
And this is going to take a--
because of the 30 seconds.
So we can go to cloud logging.
And as that is
spinning up, we'll
see it report, as we saw in
the code, I am a cold start.
That will be logged first.
So there it is.
I'm a cold start.
I'm still a cold start.
So if we go back here,
we'll see I'm a cold start.
And since we invoked it
while it was still pending,
that's where we see this.
And then as soon
as it comes back,
it will say I'm warmed up.
We see that the
request completed,
and we'll see in the logs
the function completed.
So now I am warmed
up, which is great.
But let's say we
know in advance we're
going to get future
invocations, what can
we do to-- you might
be thinking, what can
I do to have this ready to go?
Maybe this connection, database
connection already established,
or this API call, have
that value already cached,
ready to go when there is--
when you can predict
that you're going
to have future invocations.
And that's where min
instances comes in.
And now you'll see me
redeploy the function using
min instances.
So let's go to edit.
And then, in these advanced
features, scroll down,
you'll see min instances.
And instead of using
0, let's give it 5.
And deploy that.
Now that this function has
been deployed with the new min
instances, we can go here and
see in details now that we
have five min instances.
We can confirm that.
If we go to the logs now
and rerun this query,
you'll see the call
function's updated.
And you might think that this
is off by one, but instead
of five cold starts because,
remember, we're spinning up
five instances, you
might be thinking, well,
why am I seeing six?
Well, this first one is
called a health check.
This is just to make sure that
your call function builds.
And as a part of--
not being invoked,
but just builds.
And since this is
in global scope,
that's going to get executed.
But this is just a
health check just
to make sure that the coding--
there wasn't like a compile
error, or build error,
or I'm missing dependency
or the function, identity,
lock permissions, that's
what this health check is.
So that's why you
see six of these.
And now, if we were to go--
we'll go back to the function.
Go back to trigger.
And you see, now you noticed
that it hit instantly.
And if we go to cloud run--
I'm sorry, run query.
We may see that all the
instances were warm,
and you see I'm a warm instance.
So as you just
saw, you might want
to consider using
min instances to keep
a certain number of your
Cloud Functions instances
warm in case you're expecting
an increase in traffic
or you just need to get the
best latency times possible.
Now, for the second
demo, you're going
to see how a Cloud Function
can listen for and respond
to a cloud audit log event.
For example, let's
say that a company
has a policy where
their engineers need
to put their user name
as a label on any VM
that they create.
Well, you can have a checklist
for their engineers to follow,
but they might forget or
they might have a typo.
And so one of the best ways
to reduce human error is to,
quote, "automated out."
So instead, you could
write a Cloud Function
to listen to a cloud audit
log event for whenever
a VM is created and have the
Cloud Function automatically
label the VM with their
user name instead.
In this second
demo, you'll see how
you can use a Cloud Function
to listen for and respond
to a cloud audit log event.
In this scenario, you'll see
a Cloud Function automatically
label a VM using the user name
of the person who created it.
So first, let's go over
how to deploy a function
to respond to a cloud
audit log event.
Now, notice in this deployment
you'll specify the trigger
event filters.
So we have a type,
cloud audit log.
Service name is compute.
And insert instances when
a new instance is created.
So let's deploy that.
And while that deploys, let's
take a look at the code.
So the first thing to
notice is that the signature
for the function event
handlers is different
and now it's cloudevent.
And so we grab the data from
the cloudevent data payload.
And just in case an event
has more than one audit log,
we want to make sure
we're responding
to the very last event.
The resource names, they look
like in this particular case.
And so we want to break it
up and grab the instance
name and the user name.
And we log appropriately.
Now, if you're trying
to-- like in this case,
set a label, the API,
make sure that you're
setting the most recent label.
And so you need to get the
instance label fingerprint,
otherwise you're not going
to be able to set the label.
And then we can
invoke the VM label.
And then, finally,
we log the results.
So let's look at the
setVMLabel, the more interesting
of the two.
So here's the API call.
We set up instanceName,
zone, project.
Resource here, I have the
label named as creator.
And then you'll see my
user name for this account.
And then we make the API call to
set the label for the instance.
Now, let's take a peek.
And yes, our cloud function
has finished deploying.
So let's jump over
to Cloud Console,
and every refresh we'll see
the vmlabelerdemo is up.
So let's go to the VMs
and create a new VM.
And we'll just use the defaults.
And as soon as that is created,
you'll see the label is added.
And the nice thing about having
a Cloud Function automatically
perform this task
is one less thing
that you have to ask your
engineers or your developers
or whoever is doing
the particular task.
It's one less thing for
them to remember to do.
So instead of having a long
checklist of, did I do this?
Did I do that?
The more you can automate
that out, the less human error
you will have.
So let's go to the instance.
And now you can see
that the creator
is drofaras, which
is my user name,
or my full name, Sara Ford
spelled backwards for my demo
account purposes.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Thank you, Sara,
for those amazing
and exciting demos.
So that's a wrap, folks, with
our session on Cloud Functions.
Please check out Cloud Functions
at cloud.google.com/functions.
Please also sign up for
the advanced features
that we've covered
in this session.
You can do so by
reaching out to us.
Further, if you
have any questions,
please feel free to
reach out to us as well.
Thank you, and have
a great conference.